We started to have a discussion about the
laws of Amira L'Nochri and we gave a
background fundamental shiur about what is the reason
why Amira L'Nochri is prohibited. Why are you
not allowed to ask a Gentile to do
forbidden activity for you on Shabbos when in
fact the Gentile themselves is not obligated to
keep Shabbos. So what is the problem? We
spoke about that last time and now we're
going to talk about an extension of this
issue which is not exactly the same but
is something that comes up all the time
and is very interesting and very very important
and it has a number of different variations
to the question. First variation that we're going
to talk about is the following. What happens
when you have a Jew in the summertime
when Shabbos comes in at 7:45. I don't
want to wait until 7:45 so I am
mekabel Shabbos early. I bring in Shabbos let's
say at 6:30 or 6:00 and then I
have plenty of members of my community who
do not accept Shabbos at the same time
as I do. And then I realize after
I already accepted Shabbos that I forgot to
do something but it's already Shabbos for me.
Am I allowed to ask one of the
Jews that I am familiar with to do
an activity that for me, I myself would
not be allowed to perform because it's already
Shabbos. I have accepted it upon myself at
six and for them they're not going to
accept Shabbos until 7:45. That's question number one.
Which is then going to lead us into
question number two. Question number two is I'm
sure many of us have been in Israel
for the Chagim for Yom Tov and when
a ben Chutz L'Aretz, when a member of
the diaspora goes to Eretz Yisrael for Yom
Tov you are supposed to keep two days
of Yom Tov contrary to what many people
think. We are supposed to keep two days
of Yom Tov when we're in Eretz Yisrael.
There are certain permutations when people don't but
the I can't say the consensus but it
seems the overwhelming opinion in the poskim is
that you're supposed to keep two days of
Yom Tov when you're in Eretz Yisrael. So
I'm keeping the second day of Yom Tov
but my Israeli neighbor who has the house
or the apartment right next door obviously it's
not Yom Tov for them. Am I allowed
to ask them to do something that I
myself would not be allowed to do because
for me it's Yom Tov and for them
it's not? Or would you say that the
same rules that apply by Amira L'Nochri on
Shabbos should also apply to this situation and
this circumstance? Which is going to lead us
to discussion number three which is let's say
there was something on Shabbos that I am
careful not to do. For example there are
many people that don't carry in the eruv.
The Mishnah Berurah says even if you have
a good eruv and people are checking it
and people are vigilant the Mishnah Berurah says
ba'al nefesh yachmir. A person should try if
they don't have to use the eruv they
shouldn't use the eruv. So let's say I
don't use the eruv but I have a
next door neighbor who does. Am I allowed
to ask the next door neighbor to carry
something for me on Shabbos to shul that
I forgot to bring before Shabbos? Or if
I do not open up bottle caps on
Shabbos and I have somebody sitting at my
table who does, am I allowed to ask
them to do something, can they be my
Shabbos goy, right? Can that Jew sitting at
my table be the person who is going
to do something that I believe is forbidden
or perhaps not? Let's discuss all of this
because I think it's really interesting and really
important for us to know because these kinds
of situations come up all the time. Yes.
Is this the same as an Ashkenaz person
asks a Sefard? Correct. Same same thing. Yes.
All part of the same discussion. We don't
have enough time so let's try to get
through as much as we can so that
we can discuss the issue. In order to
understand the beginning of this problem or the
beginning of the solution to this problem let
us first give a little bit of background
about the prohibition of Tosefes. First of all
when we talk about Tosefes Shabbos. What is
Tosefes Shabbos? How do you add on to
Shabbos? What does that mean? Either it's Shabbos
or it's not Shabbos. What does Tosefes mean?
This is an idea, this is a concept
that is born from the idea of Yom
HaKippurim. The Gemara says in Masechet Yoma daf
pey-aleph amud-bet that we have a concept of
Tosefes Yom HaKippurim which means Yom Kippur is
really from sundown to sundown but the Torah
seems to indicate that we are supposed to
already usher in Yom HaKippurim before sundown even
comes to be. So we're supposed to take
a little bit of the day before Yom
Kippur add it on to extend it on
to Yom Kippur itself and that is called
Tosefes Yom HaKippurim. If you look in the
Rambam, the Rambam says that is limited to
Yom HaKippurim. That's the only place the Gemara
talks about this idea of Tosefes. And surprisingly
the Rambam does not mention it by Shabbos
or Yom Tov, which is very shocking. We're
all familiar with the fact that women light
candles 18 minutes before sunset, right? Or in
Yerushalayim they light candles I think more than
that. 40 minutes before sunset. So we all
have this idea, this notion in our heads
of Tosefes, but surprisingly the Rambam himself doesn't
mention it. How does the Rambam leave it
out? Good question but all the other Rishonim
disagree and they all say the same way
the Gemara tells us that there's a concept
of Tosefes that you're supposed to extend Shabbos,
you're supposed to extend Yom Kippur so too
there's a concept of extending every every Shabbos
and every Yom Tov as well. How much
you're supposed to extend is an excellent question.
Is there a limit? Rav Moshe Feinstein writes
in a Teshuvah just a couple of minutes
would be sufficient. My father has a very
interesting shita which is based on a comment
of Rabbeinu Peretz in Maseches Beitzah daf lamed
where Rabbeinu Peretz seems to say that tosefes,
that adding on to Shabbos or Yom Tov
or Yom Kippur would only be thirty minutes.
So my father himself is machmir that he's
mekabel Shabbos thirty minutes early every Shabbos, which
doesn't sound like a big deal, but in
the wintertime when Shabbos is at 4:15 and
you're accepting Shabbos at 3:45, it's not so
pashut. It's not so easy, but my father's
a yarei Shamayim and that's what he does.
He's always mekabel Shabbos thirty minutes early. Okay,
but that's the details of Kabbalas Shabbos, we
could talk about that another time, but now
for the purposes of our discussion, we need
to know that there's a concept of Tosefes
Shabbos that we generally think about. Now in
that time of Tosefes, this is the question
that we presented: when it's already Shabbos for
me, but it's not Shabbos for you because
I extended Shabbos and I brought it in
two hours early, would I be allowed to
ask somebody who has not yet accepted Shabbos
to do something on my behalf or perhaps
not? So here we go. You ready? Here
we go. We have a concept in Hilchos
Shabbos that is referred to as Issur Techumin.
What does Issur Techumin mean? Issur Techumin means
we have a prohibition for a person to
go out of a certain designated location on
Shabbos. That is actually learned from a pasuk
in this week's parsha. In this week's parsha
we read the Jewish people come out of
Mitzrayim. What happens after they come out of
Mitzrayim, they realize we don't have any food,
what are we going to do? And the
Jewish people start looking around, where are we
going to find food? We're in the desert,
we're stuck. Let's go back to Egypt. Moshe
Rabbeinu says no no we're going to stay
here. We came out of Egypt, we're out
of Mitzrayim, God's going to take care of
us. Hakadosh Baruch Hu sends the mann. What
was the infrastructure, what did everyone have to
do? The process was that you go and
collect your mann every day and that is
what you were going to feed your family
with. Okay. Hakadosh Baruch Hu tells them I
want you to know: Re’u ki Hashem nasan
lachem es haShabbos. I want you all to
know that I'm giving you the mitzvah of
Shabbos, which is really interesting because if you
were to ask nine out of ten people
when did Hashem give us the mitzvah of
Shabbos, what would they say? At Har Sinai.
It's one of the Aseres Hadibros, correct? So
we would have said, our natural response would
have been that Hashem gave us the mitzvah
of Shabbos at Har Sinai. After all, on
the luchos it says: Zachor es yom haShabbos
lekadesho. But yet, if you look in the
pesukim in this week's parsha, it is clear
that Hashem actually gave us the mitzvah of
Shabbos before we got to Har Sinai. The
mitzvah of Shabbos was given right when the
Jewish people came out of Mitzrayim, right when
they engaged with the mann for the first
time, Hashem gave them the instructions and he
said: I know that every day you are
going to be collecting mann and bringing it
into your home, however, on Shabbos, Al yeitzei
ish mimekomo beyom hashevi’i. Sorry, beyom hashevi’i. Shevu
ish tachtav. Everyone has to stay in their
place, Al yeitzei ish mimekomo. Now what does
that mean Al yeitzei ish mimekomo? Really? You
believe there were no young toddlers in the
days of Yetzias Mitzrayim? Every single young child
the entire duration of Shabbos had to stay
locked up in their little tents and wasn't
allowed to go play with their neighbor? Of
course that's not what it means. What does
the Torah mean when it says that on
Shabbos everyone has to stay exactly where they
are? Well, the answer to that is you
have to define what is my makom? What
does it mean I have to stay in
my place? What is my place? Does my
place mean my home or is there a
more expansive definition of my place? The answer
again, a very complicated set of halachos, but
I'm just going to boil it down very
simply as follows. My home is not considered
to be my only place that I'm allowed
to go on Shabbos. Of course, all of
us know we go to shul, we go
to friends, we eat out, we go all
over the place on Shabbos, or we're allowed
to. The answer is if I'm part of
a Jewish community, the entire community is considered
to be part of an extension of my
home and I'm allowed to walk within any
of those locations on Shabbos. What happens when
I get to the edge of the town?
And now nobody else from the community lives
there anymore. That is when it's considered to
be I'm walking out of my techum. I'm
walking out of my personal space and I'm
not allowed to go further than a certain
distance outside of the city, a certain minimal
distance outside of the city. But let's say
for example I don't live in a city,
I live in the desert by myself and
I have a little hut that I live
in and that's I'm just alone. So then
I have a very limited amount of space
that I'm allowed to go on Shabbos because
my own space, personal space is considered to
be very restricted and the only amount of
room that I get around that is a
very limited area of space. With that background,
yeah? I have a question. Yeah, you can
wait? So let's wait. With that background, we're
going to go to this following scenario. One
of the students in our last class drew
it on the, if you don't like the
drawing, you can speak to her, but she
drew it for us so it will become
a little bit easier for us to understand.
Let's take two names of people who are
here now and who wants to volunteer to
be the name here? Gittel? Okay. Gittel, okay.
Gittel, great, amazing. And you, you want to
be next? Ally. Ally. Okay, Gittel and Ally
are going to be the two people that
we're talking about here. Gittel and Ally have
a certain problem that they need to deal
with on Shabbos. What's the problem? One second.
This is Ally, your last name is Nagel,
right? Ally Nagel's house. And this is Gittel,
your last name is? Friedman. So this is
Gittel Friedman's house. Good? Okay, here's the situation.
You ready? We're going to set it up
as follows. You have two people. Gittel and
Ally are very close friends and they love
each other very much. Great? Fair? Okay, you're
not in a fight. Good. Okay, the problem
is as follows. You each own a lot
of farmland and you have a lot of
produce on that farm. If you're going to
leave the farm unattended for an entire Shabbos,
obviously no one's working the farm, no one's
working the land, but you need to have
someone who's watching that nobody should steal the
produce. So the question is, what are you
going to do? To pay a security guard
to go watch my field for the entire
duration of Shabbos is going to cost me
a lot of money. Now that's a waste
of money because I don't need a security
guard. I can go myself. I'm not afraid
that people are going to come armed and
start stealing things. If they see me there,
they're going to walk away. So if I'm
there it will already be sufficient. Here's the
problem. You ready for the problem? The problem
is logistically Ally's field is very far away
from her house. Ally lives on the edge
of the community on this side, okay, and
her field is on the opposite edge of
the community on the other side. Gittel's field
is on this side, on this edge of
the community, and her house is on the
opposite side. So it turns out that Gittel
happens to live right near Ally's field and
Ally happens to live right near Gittel's field.
Here's the problem. When you look at how
far Ally is allowed to go on Shabbos,
here is the invisible line that allows her
to travel on Shabbos. You ready? Okay, this
is considered to be her tchum, her makom.
So Ally's house is over here. You got
it? This is her little house, good. And
we're going to draw this imaginary dotted line,
circle around her house. That is how far
she's allowed to go, which includes the local
shul. That's in the middle. Good. Go in
the other side. You have Gittel lives over
here. What's the imaginary line that she's allowed
to go around on Shabbos? So that's going
to be this. So they overlap over here.
You got it? They're overlapping in the middle,
but Ally is not allowed to go here
and Gittel is not allowed to go here.
So far so good, everyone with me? Why
can't they go there if it's the same
community? So you have to explain, meaning they're
living at different parts. Okay, so they're living
at different parts which means my tchum ends
here and her tchum ends here. Which means
that Ally would not be allowed to walk
to her field and Gittel will not be
allowed to walk to hers. They show up
in shul together and say, we have a
great idea. Instead of hiring security to be
there and pay them to be there the
whole Shabbos, I have a great idea. Why
don't you watch my field on Shabbos and
I, in turn, will watch your field on
Shabbos? After all, your field is right near
my house, it's a two-minute walk, I can
go there. And my field is a two-minute
walk from your house. So let's just switch.
I want you to watch mine and I'll
watch yours and all will be good. Is
that allowed on Shabbos? Am I allowed to
instruct you to watch my field that I
would not be allowed to walk to myself
on Shabbos because it's outside of my tchum?
It's outside of my area that I'm allowed
to walk. What do you say? Yes. Yes.
Why yes? Why is that any different? Let's
get into the trap. You ready? Tova, you
good? Yeah, let's go right into the trap.
Why yes? The answer is yes, is correct.
But why? What do you mean? You're going
to say yes because, let's hear. Because it's
permissible for me to go and walk there,
but if I lived in the other person's
house it wouldn't be allowed. Okay, but you
don't. So ostensibly what are you saying? They're
not doing anything wrong. Excellent, you walked right
into it. You ready? Why? Let me tell
you why you walked right into it. Because
what happens with amira l'nochri that we spoke
about last year? It's the other person, they're
not walking outside their tchum. Okay, and the
non-Jew that I'm asking to do something for
me on Shabbos is not doing anything wrong
because they don't have to keep Shabbos. But
it's permissible for me. Okay, and right now
when I'm asking you to watch my field,
you're doing something that I would not be
allowed to do. No, watching the field is
not assur, only travel. Walking to the field
is not allowed, but I'm asking you to
walk to the field that I would not
be allowed to walk to. But you're not
asking them to walk outside their tchum. But
I'm asking you to do something that I
can't do. The same way when I ask
a non-Jew, the same way when I ask
a non-Jew to do something on Shabbos, they're
allowed to do it on their own, it's
just I'm asking them to do something that
I'm not allowed to do. allowed to do.
So this is the question, yeah? But if
I was in their position, if I lived
in that house, the question would be different,
whereas I couldn't be a non-Jew. Correct. Okay,
so these are all good points. We're going
to touch on them in a minute, yeah?
You're not asking them to do the thing
that you're not allowed to do. The thing
you're not allowed to do is cross the
techum. You could walk to the field, but
it just happens to not be in your
techum. When you're asking them, you're not asking
them to cross the techum, you're asking them
to stay in it and just... but ostensibly
it should be the same as amirah l'akum.
You're asking them to do something that you
yourself cannot do. The bottom line the Gemara
says is this case is permissible. So you're
all right. You're all right that it's permissible.
The hard part here is to figure out
why is it allowed? How do you draw
the distinction between this and amirah l'akum? What's
the difference between this case where I'm asking
a Jew to do something that I'm not
allowed to do myself and the case of
me asking a non-Jew to do something that
I'm not allowed to do myself? That's the
question here, the million-dollar question. But let's leave
that question for a moment. We're going to
get back to it. But the basic, yeah?
Does it have anything to do with the
fact that they're both Jewish? That is what
we're talking about, but we have to figure
out why is that a difference. We have
to figure out why is that a difference.
Of course that's a distinction, but we have
to figure out why that's a difference. So
let's just hold on to all these thoughts
for a moment. From here, from here the
Rashba quotes in the name of the Ba'alei
haTosafot. From here we can learn to another
case, and that is if I accept Shabbos
early and my friend has not yet accepted
Shabbos. So even though I am not allowed
to go do a melacha, forbidden activity, because
it's Shabbos for me, but there's no problem
for me to ask my Jewish friend to
do a melacha because for them it's not
Shabbos, for them there's nothing wrong. Say the
Ba'alei haTosafot you can prove that from this
case. Because over here I am asking a
Jew to do something that I am not
allowed to do, but for them it's totally
permissible. Similarly I'd be allowed to ask a
Jew when it's already Shabbos for me but
not Shabbos for them to do something on
my behalf. That is what the Rashba says
in the name of the Ba'alei haTosafot. Yeah?
Is it like the idea of like a
non-Jew is like an extension of you but
a Jew would be like a separate... A
Jew even more so is an extension of
me. Well I would think with the whole
thing in this legal case. Legally we would
say that it applies equally, meaning shlichut for
sure works by a Jew. The question is
why does it work by a non-Jew? We
never accept a non-Jew as the shaliach. Okay
now go to the back end of Shabbos.
Anybody here have a custom in their family
to wait Rabbeinu Tam's zman after Shabbos is
over? Yeah, so you wait extra time. How
much extra? Seventh. So you're probably an extra
25 minutes more than other people, right? Okay.
So in that extra 25 minutes, remind me
your name? Talia. Talia really wants to have
something taken care of. Problem is for her
it's still Shabbos, but for everybody around her
they already ended Shabbos 25 minutes ago. So
would Talia be allowed to ask one of
her Jewish neighbors who already said Havdalah and
davened Maariv to do a forbidden activity that
she would not be allowed to do? Would
you say that that's allowed or not? Would
that fall under ve'daber davar? Why wouldn't this
fall under ve'daber davar? Oh well that's not...
that's not the same as asking, that's not
the same as taking a... forget this case.
Why would Tosefet Shabbos fall under ve'daber davar?
It probably should. But yet we just said
it's allowed. And the Shulchan Aruch actually quotes
that l'halacha and says you'd be allowed to
do that. The Shulchan Aruch in siman reish
samech gimmel seif yud zayin writes yeish omrim
mi shekibel alav shabbos kodem chasheicha. If somebody
accepts Shabbos before it gets dark outside I'm
allowed to tell Yisrael chaveiro la'asot lo melacha.
I'm allowed to instruct my Jewish friend to
do an activity on my behalf. But why
would that not violate ve'daber davar? So hold
on to that for a second. You're a
million percent right. That's the bomb question here.
That's what we need to ask. But let's
first get down the facts. So one second.
The Rema says well the same way that
we say when Shabbos comes in during that
extra period of time, the extended part of
Shabbos, I'd be allowed to instruct somebody else
to do an activity for me, so too
on the extended part of Shabbos on the
other end it would be the same. And
I'd be allowed to instruct someone when I'm
waiting for Rabbeinu Tam's zman and somebody else
is not, I would say that I'm allowed
to ask them to do some forbidden activity
that I myself am not allowed to do.
Now the million dollar question that all of
you are asking is I don't understand, why
wouldn't this be a violation of ve'daber davar
or shlichut or all the other reasons that
we said for amirah l'akum not being allowed
on Shabbos should also apply here and should
also lead us to the conclusion that you
would not be allowed to instruct somebody else
to do something on your behalf because you're
not allowed to talk about melacha on Shabbos
or because it's like a shlichut, it's like
the person is an extension of me, so
how is that... not allowed. If you look
in the Magen Avraham and the Taz and
the Mishnah Berurah and the Shulchan Aruch HaRav
and the Beis Yosef, everyone tries to explain
away why it is that this is permissible
and why it is that it's not doesn't
fall into the neat category of Amirah l'akum,
it should be just as prohibited as that.
I was talking to my father the other
day. He said, he said, you know, all
of them are giving very technical answers. Meaning
the Taz writes, the Taz says the answer
is Davar Davar only applies. Davar Davar again
just to remind ourselves, Davar Davar means there's
certain things you're not allowed to talk about
on Shabbos. Writes the Taz, if you look
here, the Taz is on number hei. The
Taz says the only time Davar Davar applies
is when I'm talking about something that is
assur lechol Yisrael. Davar hashaveh lechol adam miYisrael.
It's only when I'm talking about an activity
that no Jew is allowed to do on
Shabbos. But if I'm talking about something that
half the Jewish community is allowed to do
and half the Jewish community is not allowed
to do right now, that wouldn't be a
violation of Davar Davar. Okay, not so convincing,
but that's what the Taz says. If you
look in the Magen Avraham, he's not so
convinced of that either, he gives his own
variation to explain it. And in shlichus as
well, the Shulchan Aruch HaRav tries to explain
why it's not a problem of shlichus. My
father said a much simpler answer that goes
as follows. Here's the simpler answer: we all
go to shul on Yom Kippur, correct? At
the end of Yom Kippur, what's the last
thing we do before we davven Maariv? What?
Ne'ilah. What's the last part of Ne'ilah before
we davven Maariv? It's not a trick. Shofar,
we blow the shofar. Let me ask you:
are you allowed to blow a shofar on
Shabbos and Yom Tov? What? No. You're not
allowed to. It's prohibited. So then how do
we blow the shofar on Yom Kippur before
we say Havdalah? We do, of course we
do. Right? What? It is after Tzeis. It
is, but it's still Shabbos, it's still Yom
Kippur. Are you allowed to eat then? Why
not? It's after Tzeis. So what's the answer?
Have you ever heard somebody scream out Hamavdil?
No. So what's going on? What do you
davven? Atah Chonantanu. How is Rabbi Rice allowed
for them to blow the shofar on, how
does he blow the shofar on Yom Kippur?
You're not allowed to blow the shofar on
Shabbos and Yom Tov. I'm going to have
a word with him. Right, so what's the
answer? Every single shul in the world does
the same thing. How do we do it?
This is not my question. This is the
question of the Ba'alei HaTosfos in Masechet Megillah
on daf daled amud aleph where they say,
I don't understand, it's still Yom Kippur, you
didn't say Havdalah yet. If you didn't say
Havdalah, you're not allowed to do any prohibitions
on Shabbos. How are you allowed to blow
the shofar if you're generally not allowed to
blow the shofar on Shabbos and Yom Tov?
Very simple straightforward question. The answer that Tosfos
says is blowing the shofar is not one
of the melachos. It's what he refers to
as a chochmah she'einah melacha. Which means Tosfos
is telling us that in the time of
Tosefes Shabbos, meaning by the time we get
to the blowing of the shofar, Yom Kippur
is already basically over. You said it's Tzeis
hakochavim, right? It's just we didn't say Havdalah
yet, so we extended Yom Kippur. Says Tosfos,
whenever you have the extended part of Shabbos
or Yom Tov, the only prohibitions that you
have at those times are actual 39 melachos
or the categories of melacha, our forbidden activities
then. But if you have some other area
of the laws of Shabbos that is not
a melacha but is a separate prohibition of
Shabbos outside of the categories of the 39
melachos, Tosfos says you're allowed to do one
of those even though you haven't yet said
Havdalah. My father likes to give the following
example: we know that on Shabbos there's a
prohibition of hachanah. What does that mean? Means
let's say we're having a big sheva brachos
in my house tonight and we have to
set up, and we're nervous because people are
going to come an hour after Shabbos, we're
not going to have enough time. When are
we going to set everything up? So you
know what? Let's just start setting up on
Shabbos afternoon. Would that be allowed? Obviously not.
Why not? Because you're in violation of the
prohibition of hachanah. Now if I were to
ask you, is hachanah one of the 39
prohibitions of Shabbos? No. It's a separate prohibition
of Shabbos that is not connected to the
39 melachos, correct? Would you be allowed to
do hachanah during the time of Tosefes Shabbos?
Let's say the end of Shabbos and now
everybody, you know, everyone's just sitting around, they
didn't say Havdalah yet and they didn't go
to shul, whatever it is. We're going to
davven in an hour for whatever hypothetically, I
don't know. Are we all allowed to come
around and say, 'You know, hey, we're all
here, why don't we start setting up for
the sheva brachos tonight now?' Instead of waiting
until after Shabbos. The answer to that my
father writes is yes. Why? Because in the
time of Tosefes Shabbos, in that period of
time, the only prohibitions that you are bound
by are actual melachos. The Mishnah Berurah writes,
and again it's somewhat restricted, but the Mishnah
Berurah says in theory, amirah lenakhri does not
apply during Tosefes Shabbos. So say for example
on a winter, on a summer Shabbos when
I make Shabbos at 6 o'clock and Shabbos
really doesn't officially come in... until eight o'clock,
let's say, and then I realize, I come
home and I realize, oy, I forgot to
set the lights and I forgot to do
this and I wanted to do that, would
I be allowed to have a non-Jew come
into my home and can I instruct them
to do all of these activities that I
didn't do before Shabbat began? The answer to
that is yes. Why? Ay, there's a prohibition
of amirah l’akum. You're not allowed to ask
a non-Jew to do things for you on
Shabbat, and it's officially already Shabbat, right? I
accepted Shabbat upon myself. The answer is that
during that time of tosefet Shabbat, during that
additional extended period of time on Shabbat on
both ends, we would say that amirah l’akum
is permissible. And my father explains the reason
why, again, the Taz and the Magen Avraham
don't say this, but my father's explanation is
because we assume that the only prohibitions that
apply during this period of time are a
melachah per se, but not any of the
other ancillary prohibitions of Shabbat that are not
directly connected to the 39 melachot. So that
is with regard to that. We good so
far? I just have a question. Yes. Do
all people hold that you can do hachanah
during, after tosefet? I'd have to check that
up again. I worked at Camp Peale as
a waitress and I remember we weren't allowed
to clean up Shalosh Seudos because they said
it was preparing for after. When did they
finish Shalosh Seudos? Usually it's late. I think
most of the time we don't do it
because we're afraid that people are then going
to draw conclusions and do things that they're
not supposed to do. Yeah, and also it
can cause a major zilzul Shabbat, meaning once
that happens, people are going to say, 'Ah,
Shabbat is already over anyway, so I may
as well turn on my phone,' and it
could lead to other things. But theoretically, yes.
Yeah. So in the case of tosefet Shabbat,
you wouldn't have to hint to the non-Jew?
Correct. You can ask the non-Jew directly, 'Turn
on my lights.' Yes, correct. Yeah. When you
say the 39 melachot apply during tosefet Shabbat,
is that including all the toldot and everything?
Yeah, all the categories, yes. Let me give
you an example in the other direction a
little bit. Tosafot in the last perek in
Masechet Pesachim, daf tzadik tes, Tosafot talks about
the following issue, which is discussed in the
Taz and the Magen Avraham as well. Let's
say I accept early Shabbat on a summer
Shabbat, six o'clock. And it's just me and
my and my wife, or me and my
siblings, and we're all exhausted, we had a
very exhausting week, we just got back from
vacation, and we want to have a very
quick meal. So we accept Shabbat at six
o'clock. We say, 'You know what? We're going
to have a meal, 25 minutes, we're going
to sleep.' That means you're going to finish
your entire meal before it's even dark outside,
before it's officially Shabbat for most of the
people. The Taz discusses, would that work or
not? Are you in fulfillment of the mitzvah
of Seudat Shabbat if you started and finished
your entire meal of Shabbat before it's even
Shabbat for most of the people? What do
you say? So the Taz writes, you should
be machmir and you should wait to have
at least a kezayit after sunset, after it's
dark outside, because otherwise you basically ate your
whole meal before it's even Shabbat. But what
do you mean? It is Shabbat, I accepted
Shabbat. The answer is, yeah, you accepted Shabbat,
but it's not like 100%, it's not Shabbat
all the way. So once you've accepted Shabbat,
you're not allowed to do melachah obviously. Of
course, you're not allowed to do other things.
You're allowed to make Kiddush, but you can't
have the entirety of the meal before Shabbat
even officially begins. That's the discussion. That's the
discussion but that's somewhat related to this. Yes,
quick question. How is tosefet Shabbat not bal
tosif? tosefet Shabbat is not bal tosif because
we have it learned from a pasuk. The
Torah says it by Yom Kippur. Wait, how
is it not like adding on to a
mitzvah? It's not because the Torah says you're
allowed to. The Torah says by Yom Kippur
that you have to add on to Yom
Kippur, so from there we learn that such
a concept exists. Once the Torah says it,
then of course we're allowed to do it.
Yeah. So in the case of if you
have a meal before, and you finish after
already counts as, and you said Kiddush before,
the idea of like, oh you can just
say it often during the day. If you
said Kiddush before since Friday night, should you
do a particular thing here? No, the Gemara
says explicitly that you're allowed to say Kiddush
even while it's erev Shabbat. The Gemara says
Rav tzalay shel Shabbat b’erev Shabbat, meaning even
while it's light outside, Kiddush for sure you're
allowed to do. The question is the meal.
Okay, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Isn't it, it's interesting
because there's certain places in the world where
Shabbat in the summer doesn't start till 11:00
PM. Right. You go to like Russia, Saint
Petersburg, yeah, then you have to wait till
11:00 PM for... It's a bigger problem the
other way. What do you do about Havdalah
on motzei Shabbat? In England, right? So it's
a big issue. There are a lot of
people who go to sleep and make Havdalah
Sunday morning. Right? You're not going to keep
your kids up till 11:00 o'clock at night.
So, big question. Okay, which now leads us
to the next, to the next... Okay, which
now leads us to the next shlav, to
the next part of this discussion. And that
goes as follows: What happens if I'm in
Eretz Yisrael and I'm observing two days of
Yom Tov because I'm a ben Chutz La'aretz,
I live in the diaspora, I'm visiting Eretz
Yisrael for Yom Tov, but there are many
Jews who are Bnei Eretz Yisrael who live
there who are only observing one day. Would
I be allowed to ask them on my
second day of Yom Tov, can I ask
them to do some kind of activity on
my behalf or not? Well, let's first back
up a step. Let's try to understand, what
is this Yom Tov Sheni all about? What's
going on? Why do we have Yom Tov
Sheni? Yeah? This is like during the whole
like half a day, keep a day and
a half. No, you're getting fancy. That's like
advanced Talmud. This is somebody who goes to
Israel from Chutz La'aretz who's keeping two days
legitimately, wants to know whether they're allowed to
ask somebody else to do a melacha for
them. Okay, so let's try to understand what
is this whole Yom Tov Sheni about in
the first place. Why do we have two
days of Yom Tov? It's referred to as
Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyos. People say Golias,
it's not, it's Galuyos, right? When I was
in fourth grade, I had a Brachos bee.
So what happens at a Brachos bee? Ever
been part of such a thing? So at
a Brachos bee they ask questions and everyone
studies, fine. So what happened? So I won
the Brachos bee, which means then you go
to the, I don't know, inter-school and thing,
whatever. So then, what do they do? There's
only so many Brachos you can ask about.
It gets to a point where like there's
nothing left in the material to ask. So
we were at the, you know, whatever, the
finals championship, whatever, I have no idea. And
the question I got, they were making up
new questions that we were just supposed to
know without studying. So they asked me, the
question I got out on was: who instituted
Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyos? I was in
fourth grade. How am I supposed to know
that? Right? So I said obviously it was
Golias, right? Like why else would we call
it that? Which I stepped right into their
trap. That's not the right answer. It doesn't
mean Golias. It's Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyos,
which means Jews who live in the exile,
Jews who live in the diaspora have to
keep two days of Yom Tov. Why do
they keep two days of Yom Tov? What's
this all about? So the reason why is
because we read in last week's parsha how
are we, how do we determine Rosh Chodesh
every month? The answer is the moon becomes
visible, a small sliver, a small crescent of
the moon becomes visible and we have witnesses
who come to the Beis Din in Yerushalayim
and say, by the way, we want you
to know, we're reporting that we saw the
moon. And we interrogate them, we make sure
they're telling the truth, okay, whatever, fine. Then
we're going to send out messages that everyone
should know today is Rosh Chodesh. Sounds good.
Here's the problem. How are we going to
get the message out? We didn't have emails,
we don't have text messages, no WhatsApp. How
is everyone going to find out? So in
the early days, the mishna says, they used
to go on the top of every mountaintop
in Yerushalayim, they would light a big fire.
And if somebody is standing on top of
it holding a big fire, then the person
at the next mountain and the next town
is going to do the same thing, and
within a couple of hours everyone's going to
find out very efficiently. Here's the problem. There
was a group of Jews by the name
of the Kusim who were trying to undermine
the whole system of traditional Orthodox practice. So
they decided we're going to go two days
in advance and we're going to start lighting
the fires on the mountaintops. And then everyone's
going to think today is Rosh Chodesh, which
means it's going to throw off the whole
calendar. And then it caused major confusion. So
they decided, you know what? Because of that,
we're not going to have this system anymore.
We're going to come up with a new
system. What's the new system? New system they
came up with is after we declare Rosh
Chodesh in Yerushalayim in the Beis Din, we're
going to send actual messengers to every community
to make sure that they become aware of
the fact that we declared Rosh Chodesh. Okay,
sounds like a great idea. Here's the problem.
You're a messenger coming out of the Beis
Din in Yerushalayim traveling on your horse and
buggy. How far are you going to get?
How much time is it going to take
you to get to the furthest place in
the land of Israel? Anybody know? What? What's
the longest amount of time it could take
you, back in the days of the mishnayos,
before cars and before planes and helicopters? What's
the longest period of time it could take
a person to get from Yerushalayim to the
furthest place in the land of Israel? Anybody
know? A day or two? A day or
two? No, forget the two days for a
minute. You're thinking too much. Just think, how
much? Two to three weeks. So you say
two weeks. You're correct. You are correct. How
do I know you're correct? The mishna says,
when in Israel do they start saying vesein
tal umatar after Succos? When do they start
saying it? Anybody know? Shemini Atzeres? No, they
start saying mashiv haruach on Shemini Atzeres. No,
December 4th is in Chutz La'aretz. A week
later? No. Zayin Cheshvan. Zayin Cheshvan. Why do
we start saying it on Zayin Cheshvan? Anybody
know? Think about the calendar for a minute.
Zayin Cheshvan is two weeks after Yom Tov
is over. And the Gemara says if we're
going to start saying the same Tal Umatar
right away after Sukkos, what's going to be
with all those farmers who came all the
way from the Galil or all the way
from the bottom of the country from Otef
Aza and are now traveling back and they're
all going to get stuck in the mud
and stuck in the rain? That's not right,
then they're not going to want to come
Olei Regel, they're not going to want to
visit the Beis Hamikdash next time. So we
hold off the whole Bakasha for rain for
two weeks because we're afraid that the farmers
are going to get stuck on the way
home. Which means the Mishna says that the
maximum amount of time it could take anyone
to get from Yerushalayim to the furthest location
in the land of Israel is two weeks.
Okay. So good. So you have the Shaliach,
you have the messenger goes, the emissary of
the Beis Din goes out and they're sending
people all over to inform everybody. It's going
to take some communities two weeks until they
find out when Rosh Chodesh was, which is
still okay because Pesach is on the 15th
day of the month. So imagine the guy
shows up on Erev Pesach, he says, I
got some great news for all of you,
I want you to know tonight is the
Seder. And everyone's like, what do you mean?
I didn't clean the house, I didn't prepare
anything, I didn't make Matzah. So this is
very distressing. But what about the community that's
16 days out? What do you do about
them? You think there were no Jews who
lived a little bit further out of the
boundaries of Eretz Yisrael? There were. There were
Jews who lived in other locations too. So
what do you do if you're the community
that lives 16, 17 days out or if
you live in the United States, they're never
going to get to you? The answer is
you have to observe two days of Yom
Tov because you're not 100% sure when it's
Rosh Chodesh. You see when the moon shines,
you're not sure, is today the first day
that the moon shined or the second day?
So that's why we observe two days of
Yom Tov. Good? This way we're never going
to have this issue. Okay. So in exile,
in diaspora, the Jews observe two days of
Yom Tov, and in Eretz Yisrael they only
observe one. Okay. Along comes the Maharikash. You
probably never heard of the Maharikash. I never
heard of him either. Who is the Maharikash?
The Maharikash was one of the great, great
Gedolim, one of the great Poskim in Mitzrayim,
in Egypt, in the second half of the
1500s. He passed away in 1612. His name
was Rabbi Yaakov Castro and he was a
Talmid of the Radbaz. The Radbaz was one
of the great Rishonim. And the Maharikash is
quoted by the Birchei Yosef and by the
Shaarei Teshuva as saying what happens when somebody
from outside of the land of Israel goes
to visit for Yom Tov? Now why is
he the first person to ask this? Why
is he the first person to ask it?
Because nobody before him ever thought to do
such a thing. You had in the days
of the Rishonim in the 1200s, 1300s, they
lived in France and in Spain. The Ramban
moved to the land of Israel, but he
moved there so he didn't have this question.
There was no such phenomenon as Jews who
lived in the diaspora who are coming to
visit for Yom Tov and they're going to
go back. It wasn't like today where this
is something we go back and forth. So
the Maharikash asked this question: What do you
do if you're living like me in Egypt
and you're going to go travel to the
land of Israel for Yom Tov? It's not
so far. But you want to go visit
some family or friends who live in Israel.
Would you be able to ask somebody on
Yom Tov Sheini to do Melacha for you
when it's still Yom Tov for you and
it's not Yom Tov for them? That's the
question that he asked, which is amazing. I
always think whatever you want to understand what
was going on in the times of any
particular generation of Jews, just look in the
Tshuvos books. Look at the Shailas that they
asked. Why is he asking this question? He's
asking it because nobody before him talked about
such a thing because such a thing didn't
exist. This was a new phenomenon. So this
is a major, major question as to whether
or not you'd be allowed to do that.
It seems for the Sfardiyos in the room,
Rav Ovadia Yosef is Meikel. How many Sfardiyos
do we have? Rav Ovadia Yosef says he
thinks we can be Meikel and he says
he doesn't see any issue. The same way
we allow this case of the Tchum and
the same way we allow the case during
Tosefet Shabbos on both ends that you're allowed
to ask a Jew to do something for
you, so too you'd be allowed to ask
a Jew here on the second day of
Yom Tov to do something on your behalf
as well. However, the overwhelming majority of the
Poskim seem to say that they don't agree
with that. The overwhelming majority, Rav Akiva Eiger
writes like this and the overwhelming majority of
other Poskim seem to say that this is
something that is not advised. This is something
that should be avoided and it's something that
should not be done. And the question you
need to ask yourself is why? What's the
difference between the case of Tosefet Shabbos where
you're allowed to ask someone and the case
that we're describing here of second day of
Yom Tov where you would be allowed, where
you would not be allowed to ask someone,
correct? What's the difference? So how can you
think of a difference? It's not Tosefet for
you. What? It's not Tosefet for you. Good,
good. You're correct. Yeah. The answer is, speak
it out a little more. It's not Tosefes
for you because the extra day is only
because it actually might be Yom Tov. Exactly,
meaning Tosefes means right now I decided to
accept upon myself something extra. So there are
leniencies during that extra period that you took
upon yourself. Here on Yom Tov Sheni this
is not optional. Yom Tov Sheni is an
obligation that you have. It's not the same
as Tosefes and therefore we would assume that
many say that this is something that cannot
be transferred to that Halacha. We would not
say that Yom Tov Sheni is the same
as the Zman of Tosefes. Here's the major
problem. Ready for the problem? We keep how
many days of Succos? Eight? No, not overall.
Seven. How many days of Yom Tov do
we observe? One. Two. Which one? Two. Good,
two days of Succos. How many days of
Pesach? Two. Two. How many days of Shavuos?
Two. How many days of Rosh Hashanah? Two.
How many days of Yom Kippur? One. Oh.
Wow. Can I ask you, why does anyone
observe one day of Yom Kippur? You observe
two days of everything else. What's with Yom
Kippur? It's like right after Rosh Hashanah. Okay,
but how do you know about Rosh Hashanah?
The Shluchim had no time to get to
you for Rosh Hashanah. Right? Rosh Hashanah you
need two days because you really don't know.
That's on the first day of the month.
So Rosh Hashanah you're really stuck. You can't
say Yom Kippur is ten days later and
therefore we know because we weren't actually sure
when Rosh Hashanah is. Even in Eretz Yisrael
when they don't keep two days of anything
else, they keep two days Rosh Hashanah. So
is this a question you ever thought about?
We keep two days of everything else and
somehow Yom Kippur falls through the shuffle. What
are you going to say? Yom Kippur is
D'rabbanan? No, Yom Kippur is actually as D'oraisa
as it comes. It's Shabbos Shabboson. It's pretty
serious. So we're not worried? Why do we
not have two days Yom Kippur? In fact,
the Tur v'Hagahos Minhagim quotes that there were
some Rishonim. In the days of the Rishonim,
there were Chasidim v'Anshei Maaseh who used to
keep two full days of Yom Kippur. They
used to fast two full days straight. Who
used to fast two full days? One second.
They used to fast two full days straight.
Why do we not do it? Says the
Rema, the reason why we don't do it
is because Bella is correct, that people are
going to lose their lives. It's not healthy.
It's hard enough to fast one day of
Yom Kippur. How do you expect that major
communities are going to have every person observing
two full days of Yom Kippur in a
row? So because it's a potential Pikuach Nefesh,
because it's something that is just untenable, therefore
we say now that we have a fixed
calendar, we know when Yom Kippur is, we're
only going to keep that day, we're not
going to keep two days, and this is
what standard practice is all over the world.
Okay. Writes the Tur, you ready? Here's the
problem. Let's say you have the following scenario.
You're living in the days of the Rishonim
where you have many people who are Machmir
for themselves to keep two days of Yom
Kippur. I don't know anyone that does that.
It could be there are, but in the
days of the Rishonim people did. Okay. Good.
Here's the question. Yom Kippur falls out on
a Thursday, which means you're going to observe
Yom Kippur when? Thursday and Friday. Problem is,
once Yom Kippur is over, it's now going
to be Shabbos. I'm not allowed to cook
food and this is in the days before
we had a refrigerator. So what am I
going to do? I'm going to be fasting
Thursday, Friday, and now Shabbos I have no
food because I couldn't cook on Friday. And
I couldn't cook the food on Wednesday because
I had nowhere to store it. So what
do you do? Writes the Tur, would I
be allowed to go and ask my neighbor
who's not such a Tzadik like me, who's
not fasting two days Yom Kippur? Am I
allowed to ask my neighbor on Friday, look,
I'm really hungry, I need Shabbos food, can
you cook food for me so that I'll
have food for Shabbos tonight to break my
fast? Would I be allowed to do that
or perhaps not? What do you think? No.
No? Why not? Because it's still the same
thing that it might be really Yom Kippur
just on the other side? Oh. You are
a thousand percent correct. Asks the Magen Avraham,
why is it that in Hilchos Yom HaKippurim
the Shulchan Aruch says that if you observe
two days Yom Kippur you would not be
allowed to ask somebody else to cook for
you on the second day? Whereas, whereas, in
the Zman of Tosefes Shabbos, if I've accepted
upon myself that I want to say keep
Shabbos a little bit longer than everyone else,
I would be allowed to ask someone. What's
the difference? Answers the Magen Avraham like you
very correctly stated, because really everyone should be
observing two days Yom Kippur. Right? I'm observing
two days Yom Kippur but really this is
something that everyone is supposed to be doing.
When I see my neighbor eating on the
second day Yom Kippur I say to myself
I really don't understand why they're doing it.
They're very strong, very healthy, they don't have
a problem, there's no reason why they're not
fasting. Everyone should be doing what I'm doing.
And because of that, I'm not allowed to
ask someone to do something that I believe
is wrong, that's absolutely wrong. I'm not allowed
to ask someone to do that. And that
is why on the second day of Yom
Kippur I would not be allowed to ask
my neighbor who's a Jew.
You have a right to decide when you
want to take Shabbos in, I've a right
to decide when I want to take Shabbos
in, but I don't look at you and
say \"why are you not accepting Shabbos right
now?\" That's not my business, you can do
what you want, I'll do what I want.
And because of that, since you're not doing
anything wrong, there would be no problem for
me to instruct you to do this. Now,
you'll say \"why am I even talking about
this, it's so irrelevant?\" Because nobody observes two
days Yom Kippur. Where is it relevant? It's
relevant every Shabbos. If you don't open bottles
on Shabbos, and you want to ask somebody
else to open a bottle for you. Are
you allowed to do that or not? Well,
it depends. What's the reason you're not opening
bottles? Is it because you're just taking a
little extra chumrah upon yourself or you believe
it's actually assur? If you believe, like my
father believes and Rav Asher Weiss believes that
opening bottles is absolutely not permissible on Shabbos,
if you believe that's the case—there are others
who disagree don't worry, Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach,
you have what to rely on don't worry,
great people, not people, great tzaddikim. But if
you believe that the reason why you're not
opening bottles on Shabbos is because you think
it's absolutely forbidden, it's assur, then you would
not be allowed to ask somebody else either.
If you believe the only reason why you're
not opening it is because I'm just not
sure, this whole thing has so many opinions,
I don't know what it is, it's just
a chumrah, so then maybe there's what to
talk about, maybe. My father still thinks he
wouldn't be allowed to even if it's just
a chumrah, but most disagree with my father
on that point. This would be the distinction.
Writes the Magen Avraham, what do you see?
You see from Yom Kippur, we can use
that as a test case for us. You
see from the case of Yom Kippur that
if the reason why I'm not doing something
is because I believe that it's really assur
to be done, this is how you have
to keep halacha as a Jew, then I'm
not allowed to request of somebody else to
do it either. But if all I'm doing
is just a chumrah upon myself, then okay,
I'm being machmir, you're not being machmir, maybe
there's room to argue that that would be
okay. Take for another example, if I do
not carry in the eiruv, can I ask
somebody else to carry something on my behalf
or not? Clearly no. So most poskim say
it depends why you're not carrying. If you're
not carrying because you believe that the eiruv
is not a good eiruv, is not acceptable,
it's very hard to make a good eiruv.
If you live in a community where you
have somebody who really knows eiruvin, the eiruv
is probably very good. But it's not so
simple to do it. So if the reason
you're not carrying in the eiruv is because
you're not sure that the eiruv is actually
acceptable, then you're not allowed to ask anyone
else because you believe that they're doing wrong
also. But if you're not carrying in the
eiruv only because the Mishnah Berurah says, ba'al
nefesh yachmir, a person who doesn't need the
eiruv shouldn't use it if they don't have
to, then that's my personal chumrah. Who said
that that includes me asking you to do
something on my behalf? That's a question. But
this is a major discussion and again, what
I find fascinating about all this is that
if you put all of these different sugyas
together, number one, tosefes Shabbos, Chuman, Yom Tov
Sheini, Yom Kippur, and then Hilchos Shabbos with
the chumras, and Sephardim and Ashkenazim also is
the same question about we have different rules
about heating things up on Shabbos, right? Sephardim
and Ashkenazim about heating up liquids, correct? Would
a Sephardi or an Ashkenazi be able to
ask one another to do something that the
other gender is not the right word but
the other community believes is acceptable and I
believe is not allowed? Can I do that
or not? Well, it's a question. Am I
not doing it because I believe you shouldn't
be doing it either, or am I not
doing it because I just believe it's okay,
a chumrah, we're going to be machmir, the
Rama says to be machmir. So these are
all interconnected, again, a little bit technical and
complicated but a really fascinating area of halacha
to realize how it all ties together from
so many different angles and so many different
examples. But something as I mentioned that comes
up all the time, literally, this is something
that we're confronted with all the time and
something we should be...